so is it
apologies thank you uh I think Jane
uh I got another meeting so she might be
running late so we'll see
are there any Declarations of Interest
no
thank you and Minister their last
meeting then on pages four to eight
uh as everybody seen a copy of those
are we all happy with those
thank you thank you right we'll move
straight into the uh council plan then
for 23 to 27.
uh and hopefully uh it's on your uh your
iPad book
you might have some paper copies as well
we have you if I'm sorry I'm not good at
those people no it's okay it's all on
his iPad uh do you want to talk to it
then please please
[Music]
the report is to present the cabinet the
draft council plan I know the cabinet
has been clearly heavily involved in
this for the past few uh weeks now
um so
the plans before you uh what I can say
is uh aligned to the pledges that you
made uh leader at Council this has been
a
very collaborative and inclusive process
including all the scrutiny committees
and their alignment to the council plan
and the objectives are set out in the uh
Council paper last time so
back to YouTube I think uh and and open
it up for debate and there's not a lot
more to say but the council plan is
attached
just from our perspective and then I'll
I'll say it again on on Monday uh it's
been a fantastic piece away I think from
all the officers concern I think well
throughout the organization linked it
it's it's been a everybody's uh pulled
together to get this together
I think we're the first of any new
Authority you know that changed it in
May to have produced a council plan like
this and I think it looks fantastic
it sets out the store
and I'd recommend it to to us that to
like you say that we approve this draft
council plan
and take it to the council meeting on on
Monday
yeah any comments or questions on that
yes Steve thank you only to agree with
you chair I think it is a brilliant plan
there's been a lot to work on into that
we need to recognize that you know uh
the officers have done fantastic to pull
that together and to include all our
bits that we wanted from uh our feedback
from uh residents in Northeast
Derbyshire to put together a plan that
hopefully will work for them has
responded to them
um and is going to see us through the
next four years I think it's a good good
piece of work
thank you Steve anybody else Joe
yeah just quickly chair to agree with
you to endorse that um many thanks to
the officers I think this is a really
good job and it's um
um
it was I've been through it again and it
was nice and easy to read I could see
where we were going see what it was
trying to tell us see where we were
heading very well done
thank you so is anybody anywhere else no
thank you so I'll move then the
recommendations that to approve the
draft local plan are we all in favor of
that is that a secondary chair secondly
thank you it's lovely well done again
and it looks very nice Jane but we it's
a pizza
food inspired to be it's fun Trivial
Pursuit multiple Pursuits I think yeah
that's what I keep thinking as long as I
don't land on to general knowledge again
item five then the uh five-year housing
Supply land Supply the position
statement uh do you want to do David to
do that just give us a playback
yeah happy to do that chair
um so in relation to
um Council responsibilities as local
plan Authority we essentially have to
monitor
um our five year housing land Supply so
basically delivery of housing sites in
the district uh relative to our local
plan targets and publish that
information so this information is being
presented ahead of that publication
um the headline is that we have a 5.7
year housing land Supply and so it's the
right side of five obviously
um I think in terms of
um when you when you look back
um figure 2.1 includes a table that
shows delivery uh since the plan period
started 2014-15
um there's a number of years where we're
significantly over the 330 that we need
to be producing each year
um for example 2023 22 23 776 houses so
significantly oversupply and that's good
in the short term in the sense that um
essentially plan authorities are
penalized for under Supply so so we're
not in that position at the moment so
our calculation doesn't have to include
a larger buffer basically
um I think what it does mean or it does
demonstrate Reliance to some degree on
our larger sites and that's something
that we'll have to be mindful of going
forward in terms of
um local plan review
but the projections which are based on
trajectories for development of the
larger sites officers having
conversations with the developers
basically
um and accounting for sites on which
there's a planning permission granted
and ready to go basically
um we are in a healthy position at the
moment uh like I say I think the uh the
headline is positive uh but the only one
that'll be have to be closely monitored
as part of the local plan review thank
you chat thank you David any questions
for David uh Jay it's all in the report
uh I think it's something that uh We've
we've obviously got keep an eye on
and I think from adopting the local plan
you you're more have to review it
constantly don't you and it's it's
something that uh
like you say we're just over the
five-year Supply but
because people are building these houses
still fast don't just slow down that
and we'll uh otherwise we've got to find
some more land I think somewhere along
the line but it's something we will uh
yo
thank you
thank you Jack just a couple of quick
questions David
um I might be getting it wrong but
there's some latest government
um proposal suggestions about uh
increasing numbers and uh uh we're all
required to do extras is that going to
affect anything within within at your
proposal sir
so at the moment
um we we simply have to modify the
housing land Supply and as it stands
um five thousand land Supply whether you
have one or not is critical to whether
um well
I think to summarize it how much control
you have in terms of strength of your
local plan when you're making decisions
so if you don't have a five-year housing
land Supply National policy at the
moment
um basically says that you you that
there's a tilted balance essentially
um and you might be in a position where
you need to approve a site that has a
lot of concerns around it but um perhaps
the strength of a refusal isn't quite as
strong as you'd like it to be you're in
a slightly less controlled position if
you haven't got a five year housing land
Supply
um there is debate at National level
about
um so for example speeding up the local
plan production process
um and incentives to maintain a
five-year housing land Supply but their
conversations essentially it's not um uh
not definite proposals yet
thank you thank you
sorry David
um
close to my heart well not quite uh the
cool light site at some conductment and
which is looking to be
um I mean your proper term is
undeliverable mainly because of HS tools
chopping and changing around and I think
that's if I remember that site the whole
job lot's been in turmoil for a good few
years
is there anything on the on the horizon
about any houses down there or is it uh
is it completely null and void now
in terms of moving forward in The Fairly
near future
um once we've adopted local development
scheme which will set out how we're
going to go about local plan review one
of the early phases will be a call for
sites
um and that will be a time to
potentially revisit um with developers
you know potential housing sites that
could come forward in the The Next
Period of the local plan so the long and
shorter visit I don't know exactly where
we're at with that site at the moment
but in the relatively short term we
would get that information
thank you are we uh are we happy then if
I move the recommendation to know the
annual assessment of the five-year land
supply of deliverable sites for housing
I'll move that
sorry Steve
yeah you should have moved that
are we all in favor
my guilt
uh item six the council plan targets and
performance update January to March
yeah
oh yeah don't screen yeah
okay okay thank you so obviously this is
the last uh report under the old council
plan so obviously it's just come forward
for completeness uh you'll note from the
summary that there were 77 targets uh
remaining at the end of the period of 68
of those or 88 of those achieved their
outturns at the end of the council plan
period and that's been split between 38
of those at the end of Q4 and 30 of
those targets it will achieved prior uh
during the four-year period uh only nine
of the targets failed to achieve their
intended outcome out top targets during
that time and then obviously the report
shows you those targets
um at the beginning of the appendix
and then the majority are on track so
also intended to go into too much detail
I'm conscious obviously this is the last
of the reporting the old council plan
you've obviously seen site today of the
new council plan and the intention going
forward is to provide management and
members with more more of a narrative
around how we achieve what progress
we've made and more rounded information
around how we're working towards
achieving the objectives and the tactics
that have been set out of the new
council plan so in some ways it'll be a
more comprehensive information to give
members a wider feeling of how the
council is progressing forward and meet
us some of the priorities that you've
identified that you alluded to at the
beginning of the first report so unless
members have got any particular
questions are just going to leave it as
a summary today
thank you thank you thank you there any
questions on the uh The Targets in front
of us
now I've just got one question uh how
are we going with changing the
performance criteria and all that you
know obviously we've got to adopt the
local the local plan the council plan
first yes yes you're there I think we're
gonna have a culture looking at are all
the uh targets aren't we yeah so
obviously there's been a huge amount of
work in the background which taught you
you recognize so my team now will start
to be looking at how we're going to
gather the updates from all across the
organization how we're progressing
against the objectives and priorities
have been identified in the council plan
in addition to that narrative we also
want to thread in some smaller smarter
targets yeah but we'll only report on
those when we've got something to say so
I'll give you a good example the
recycling Target we have been reporting
on that quarterly but every quarter we
only have an estimate because we don't
actually get the out turn figure until
six months so it makes much more sense
to me to report to you the actual
outcome figure so you actually know has
it improved or has it not improved
rather than use an estimate which
doesn't particularly tell you anything
so I think we need to report back more
smartly when we've got actual outturns
so you can actually see the progress so
it won't be as regimented as the
previous reporting I think it's going to
be more reformative and then bringing
the hard performance data when we've got
that information so members may be aware
that we're going to be running a
residence survey later in the year
that's going to produce a lot of really
good quality data which will help us set
benchmarks or Baseline dates for a lot
of the things in council plan because
ultimately a lot of these things around
the customer objective will be measured
about with how people out there feel
we're doing with the services that will
give us a very good Benchmark and then
we'll probably go back out in two years
time do that again and then we'll be
able to see the direction of travel have
our work as an authority and also work
with Partners made a difference so we
moved forward along some of these
tactics and objectives so that's going
to give members real data that then will
give them a flavor of the direction of
travel so it won't be as regimented as
before but I think it'll be better
quality
[Laughter]
at the risk of well try not to repeat
anything cats just said but I just just
wanted to be clear that the development
of the Performance Management referring
were conscious decision yeah that would
come after the plan because we didn't
want to be trying to fit a plan to into
a Performance Management framework it
wanted to be sure about what we wanted
to achieve and then designer designer
framework around it as kath's said it
will be a mixture there's there's
clearly the need and and very
uh you know very beneficial where
possible to have proper metrics and
proper measurements so that we know is
accurate there'll always be a place for
that but as Kath said we we're going to
also provide that narrative where
actually storytelling makes more sense
in the absence of a definitive metric
and
um in the past perhaps we have
um
we've been LED too much Biometrics and
it's a misleading thing so one that
always Springs to mind and I've used
this plenty of plenty of times before we
we had a measurement about the number of
referrals we made for the GP referral
scheme that were driven by the
Commissioners as in public health
who were paying us money to make
referrals
but it's counter-intuitive because the
more referrals you had doesn't tell a
clear story what you should be doing is
trying to improve people's lives so
you're not having to make referrals so
by doing
demonstrating that you've got a bigger
problem so you've got to be really smart
about what it is we're trying to do and
that's why the plan comes first and then
the framework yeah yeah I like it it's
really good yeah thanks for that
and thanks Kath for that um so in the
absence of Jane
I'll move the uh
uh that the out turns against a council
plan 90-23 be noted
and my only favorite thank you that's
lovely
right yeah
a medium term financial plan yes Jack
the purpose of this report is to inform
cabinet of a the out turn position of
the council for the 22-23 financial year
and to approve a rollover of a small
number of Revenue budgets and to approve
the slippage in the capital program
we published this year's accounts on the
24th of May ahead of the statutory
publication deadline of the 31st of May
at this date only 30 percent of local
authorities had filed their accounts uh
by the deadline so that's a thanks to
our staff at this juncture
I won't go uh
mazars are ideal to audit the accounts
later in July and then we plan to take
the final audited account to the audit
committee on the 29th of September
I won't go through the report in detail
but will take a minute to highlight the
key key points
the general fund net cost of services
position at the 31st of March shows an
under spend of 576
000 and that's shown on table one and it
shows that the main variances you will
note one of the main the underspend on
pay this is largely the result of vacant
posts across the council as well as
are saving on the Casual budget at the
Leisure centers which hasn't been needed
whilst the work have continued at a
number of centers
I I state that it's not a deliberate
underspend uh with stuff it is the
difficulty of recruiting and not so much
retaining but recruiting staff uh and it
is common to most local authorities at
this time
the increase in energy charges had a
significant impact on the council's
budget which was built into the revised
budget the outturn reflects that
forecast without was only very small
variance of ten thousand uh ten a
thousand 10K was reported
that was a good guess uh but I won't say
it was a good guess because it wasn't
our side that guessed it it was the
other side that guessed it so they do
get the occasional thing correct
and further details of the variances can
be found at 2.6 of the report
there are a couple of budgets that we
are seeking approval to roll over these
are eight thousand pounds for the church
wall repairs and 28k for the rent reveal
valuations
both are the result of the work not
being completed before the end but both
are progressing well this year
in terms of reserves these are detailed
in tables three and four the main point
to note is the transfer of the general
fund from the resilience reserve of 334
000 is no longer uh
required and the fact that the
contribution of 327 is being made to the
reserve which will be utilized to
provide Financial resilience to the
general fund in future years as required
by the mtfb
there were very few very uh variances to
note in the HRA are shown as appendix 3.
the full details
depreciation costs are higher than
forecast the result of a change to asset
valuations at the air end the HRA
General balance is being maintained at
three million pounds
there's been quite a lot of slippage in
both the HRA and the general fund
program this year and as in previous
years approval is sought to roll over
these would to roll these budgets over
in the HRA the Acquisitions budget
hasn't been utilized this year is a
result of delayed completion and the
budget is all committed and being spent
this year
in the general from the main variances
relate to the claycross town center
project and as if it's common with such
large scale projects the timing changes
do occur but this is causing no cause
for concern all projects are on track
for completion by 2020 20
2026. finally the appendix 5 provides a
report on the treasury management
activity of the council for 22.23 and
the key points are summarized at 2.28 in
this report
I'm a we know this uh chair
on item one we note the outcome position
and the recommendation tool that the
cabinet to prove the proposed carry
forward of capital budgets as detailed
and appendix for expendits for totaling
10.783 million pounds
yeah we should
thanks Pat I'll uh I'll sign out any
questions anybody on those
and thanks again
it's all
good at the moment there's still some
scary bits in it but we'll uh
we'll come to that if you want to say
anything Jake
no no counselor Kerry's copy it all but
you're absolutely right you know
challenges ahead but we'll as we always
do we'll face them head on So yeah thank
you we're all in favor noting that
report then
thank you
I can make funding
sorry
to volunteering Community sector
infrastructure support organizations
there you go he wants to uh anybody want
to lead on that that'll be me chair
um so
um yeah this is an annual call
um that I bring to um cabinet which just
outlines the um the summary
um of outcomes
um of the grants that the core grants we
provide to the volunteering Community
sector support organizations so this is
covering the last Financial year 22 23.
um
so
um I I kind of won't go into the details
of the report one of the one of the key
things that has changed since the report
was actually
um produced is the um cabinet will
receive presentations from the four
organizations that received core grants
from us
um two in September into in October so
they will be able to do justice
um to what they've done um obviously
with our contribution and what they in
terms of the organization that they that
they are and what they and the help they
provide to Residents across the district
um this this report just gives you a
snapshot of the type of activity that
the organizations provide
um but just just kind of summarize
um figures
um last year our Council investment
remained at just over 136
um pounds and we were able to assist
over 23 and a half thousand um
households across the district with that
um we've been quite fortunate the the
investment has increased slightly um not
necessarily year on year but um for
several years it has increased and the
number of households assisted has either
been um kind of like maintained or
increased with the exception of covid we
did see a drop in household supported
um during
um sort of 20 21 21 22 but we've seen
levels kind of um uh get back to
pre-covered
um levels
um what the monitoring exercise
um shows us is that we're able to kind
of understand value for money
um in terms of the number of households
we're supporting and it also highlights
Demand on specific issues whether we're
seeing and things like debt or housing
issues um becoming a kind of a common a
common issue where residents seek help
and support on
um in appendix one
um there is a breakdown of what each of
the organizations has done in terms of
contributing to the old council plan
um but like I say in September and
October they'll be able to give you a
kind of really good overview and a
detailed overview of the of what they've
been able to do in terms of supporting
residents in the last Financial year
um but as you can see from the report
um you know residents are um seeking
advice and help on um accessing benefits
debt advice housing advice
um but we also
um from the kind of the community Side
by supporting the volunteer Center
um and um running our community action
Grant scheme
um we're able to support volunteering
opportunities which obviously have a
benefit to members of the community
um and um in Residence
um
so um yeah I won't go into any detail if
anyone's got any questions I'm more than
happy to to answer thank you Chris
that's brilliant any questions
uh about this report
thank you self-explanatory
I know we used to uh
other men didn't we the different
organizations and
uh it's just making sure that people are
not duplicating stuff I think is is in
my head there's there were similar
things but but slightly different and
the old uh provide a good service I
think
oh thank you for that and uh
we'll uh
continue with it as they say and and get
people into report
so we just need to report the uh no the
report are we happy with that
yeah all in favorite
thank you
thank you and uh I've got no urgent
items anybody else
no thank you for your attendance then
we'll close a meeting cheers thank you